he's an American boxer widely regarded
as the best fighter of his generation
and Lissa's one of the greatest boxers
of all time he's undefeated as a
professional boxer and has won 12 world
titles Forbes magazine listed him as the
highest-paid athlete in the world
he's Floyd Mayweather and here his top
ten rules for success don't think we can
do is take one day at a time you know
it's all we can do no one is perfect
every day we strive to be perfectionist
but no one is perfect I make mistakes I
make mistakes you know I've said things
that I shouldn't shouldn't have said
when I was younger I done things that I
shouldn't have done when I was younger
I'm not perfect but we live when we
learn and that's a part of growing
anybody isn't throwing back
and Floyd Mayweather jr. has another big
stunning victory to cap off his rise to
stardom jealousy people jealous are you
cause what success so anytime you
successful
it only Josie beeping beeping they're
all won't like you sometime with you in
class service some people like you when
you're in school right but I don't stop
you from going right you still go there
and be your best all right so same thing
like my job I still go into being be at
my best right hand is solid combinations
by Mayweather too much speed maybe too
much power too
here's a vicious right hand over the top
he promised he would humiliate Arturo
Gatti
before his pants
in there as Mayweather fire at will
Mayweather captured the title technical
knockout in the sixth round I mean I
think it was it was a I think I just had
a game plan I had a brilliant game plan
the game plan was to be out be very
outspoken you know I was born with
personality I was born with charisma
speak my mind speak from the heart you
know I don't hate or dislike anyone I
want to go out there you know and just
do what I do what I have to do inside
that square circle um
choose a tremendous tremendous team on
the outside that's going to help me take
things to the next level and that's what
I did good quick left hook inside by my
weather and a big right hand upstairs by
Floyd biggest shot of the night from a
would and Mayweather is trying to knock
Oscar out with a right hand
Mayweather beginning to operate like a
surgeon fighting Floyd Mayweather is a
dose of cold reality and
Mayweather go from this pinnacle
and proclaiming that he's going to
retire they fight to the finish and we
crowd to the dismay of the almost
unanimously Pro Delaware crowd
Mayweather was awarded the
split-decision victory
you got fighters that may be faster than
me
you got fighters they may hit harder
than me you got fighters that's very
athletic but you don't have no fighter
that can make adjustments like me you
don't have fires that could be on my
level
mentally it's never personal for me it's
always business every every other
fighter fight from certain things
everybody fight for what they fight for
my thing is this I keep my eyes on the
prize
I never focus on things outside the ring
my focus is the guy that's in front of
me you get to what you're trying to get
to by staying focused stand on a
parallel path I'll always have a dream
and my dream was to be the best no
matter what happens Saturday when it
comes down to boxing I'm the best at
this good quick left hook by Mayweather
as Hatton came in
sometimes it's the right hand sometimes
it's the left hook you drown for
Mayweather here in the 8th Mayweather
believes he's got Atman pick trouble
Patton continued to come forward and
allowed Mayweather close-in emphatic
fashion what a left hook
what a perfect shot
this fight is over Boyd Mayweather has a
knockout victory I feel if I work hard I
can play hard Travis this is me did
nobody get in there and put the gloves
on for me did nobody go out there on
that road and run miles and miles for me
nobody took the broken ribs nobody took
the bloody nose I did it on I dedicated
myself to my craft and I busted my ass
I'm continued to keep believing in my
skills keep listening to my father keep
listening to my uncle and sit on his
throne for 30 months round by round it
became clear the smaller Marquez could
not deal in speed and power of
Mayweather's punches and he is punished
a quadrant of a war cos at this round
brilliant combination by Mayweather if
that didn't hurt Marquez I'm not sure
what would this is the kind of
performance that will convince many that
Floyd is still the best fighter in the
world what a return to the sport 21
months off and he's better than ever in
dominant fashion Mayweather role to the
anonymous decision victory to become
great you have to follow you have to
follow greatness but to become a psychic
to become a great leader you have to be
a great follower and to be successful
you got you got to want to follow sucess
and I want every fighter to just stay
focused stay on the parallel path but
for round three honored Mayweather got
into his rhythm controlling the pace
attacking with precision that was a
stunning shot from Mayweather right on
the button
by Mayweather and a big left hook he's
landing shots cleanly inside flaws a
very much more compact or more powerful
with each passing round Mayweather's
advantages in quickness and timing
became more pronounced champagne
Hamilton speed in the coordination sets
up Boyd Mayweather is ill level Boyd
Mayweather's conditioning boys
Mayweather's applications of the sport
is at this moment unique and he stands
alone
19 years can I reflect back over my
career I can't just say I'm um I'm going
on 49 I know you can never overlook
anyone in this camp that I push myself
absolutely every fight played a major
key all 48 fights played a major key
it's not just stuff it's not just the
intelligence it's the sharp mind it's
the good chin it's a tremendous heart
I never overlooked no opponent I trained
for every fighter the same way I pushing
myself I believe in my skills and I
believe in my talent
it was legal and it's officially a gale
Ortiz is apologizing and Mayweather was
punching we can all say
was exciting in the rain
there's no blueprint on how to beat me I
can crack any DaVinci Code when I'm in
that ring I'm the best right now do you
believe you're the best in the world I
feel I'm the best ever
I broke everybody record to the record I
haven't broke it's not bragging a boast
the proof is in the pudding men like
women line numbers don't lie doesn't
matter who it it doesn't matter the
Sugar Ray Leonard Sugar Ray Robinson
Muhammad Ali doesn't matter I respect
him I take my hat off to them but you
think I gave this sport my whole life to
say there's another fighter that's
better than me absolutely not the good
part is doing the punches so he can get
back in the fight with one punch that's
it I don't think I heard about his
punches anymore
you like three or four straight right
hand is going to throw in the towel
breaker after showing em those at all
and in those say no don't throw it in
and though it's shaking his head up
their ass Sam no no don't throw a towel
in and now the referee does it for I
want to thank my team because without my
team honest would be possible it's been
a long road it's been a long journey but
you know hard work and dedication paid
off you know it's always been one of my
dreams you know to come back to the
motherland and I'm here now
it took it took 36 years but I'm here
and I want to thank all you guys for the
support I mean every time I go out there
and fight I just don't represent the red
white and blue you know Floyd Mayweather
represents the world and I had a lot of
support and once again I didn't do it by
myself I had a tremendous team and a lot
of people supporting me for all those
that came you know flew up to Las Vegas
to see me or wherever I was fighting
that you know I'm very very thankful for
everybody that that bought pay-per-view
and for my team working with you guys to
get me over here it's truly a dream come
true
astral of bhabhiji prett as Mayweather
looks for another opportunity to land
the right hand bangs the left to the
body
d pert now fiddling with the nose as he
tries to get the blood flow to stop and
Mayweather comes back with rights and
deeper to go down and press it Joe
Cortez says that'll do one minute 28
seconds in the first round or about a
minute and a half of the first round
something like that and Floyd Mayweather
has yet another quick KO victory some
guys get some guys gambling we're gonna
be going Russia may not be going Russia
okay what's the second gameplay as plan
eight what's plan B Pacquiao he could
set the trap for other fighters but you
can't set the trap for Floyd Mayweather
because you got to have plan a he upped
a plan a plan B enough to plan if you
don't have a plan B did you go to Plan C
I've never beat a fighter with my a-game
guys shake your legs he's got a bite
time here well he's not the type of guy
that knows how to do it
every situation for heaven
this fight is over whoa
now victory
Mayweather dealt with a situation in
terror
never been confronted with before thank
you guys so much for watching I made
this video because Anton Turner asked me
to so there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave it in
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do I'd also love to know which of
Floyd Mayweather's top 10 rules had the
biggest impact on you leave it in the
comments I'm going to join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon